reject nation i'm cosplaying today is
terry silver
[Laughter]
dude that ponytail wow
guys if you go ahead and hit that like
button that would be very much
appreciated also we are watching season
4 episode 7 today
minefields
subscribe
click that notification bell you know if
i want to reaction the next one is up
full length watch along as we sync up
with the time code over our patreon page
major thanks to all it becomes parajects
today andrew gordon of course our ck
expert over here thank you so much for
being here follow me on the movie source
channel lastly the last uh all the
instructions i'm giving you today thank
you to the boys over at prep for helping
us edit these down really does help a
lot anywho guys let's get into action
wolf um spoiler alert it's not even a
bad werewolf well now i don't want it
yeah uh you try animal farm you know
that reminds me of the guy who used to
live next to elementary school uh mr
landry it'd be nice to be friends like
that again yeah uh friends
hey strawberry ghosts oh no
rivalries of bruin
looks like everyone's doing something
new
he must join a dojo to get her you know
if he joins me aggie though he could
fight kenny didn't see that coming how
many points do you think new kid had on
the roof on tonight
20 oh and that's not even counting
stealing his girl okay screw you dude
easy man
just busting balls
what balls yeah
puberty his hair like that and his
busting balls just saying
oh no
no no
he's in decent shape okay
[Music]
guys
the kid is fit it's fine i'm serious
even if he wasn't it would be fun
man
yeah tournaments in a month
since he's gonna be kicking our ass all
week your student is ready for some
intense training
oh is he forgot my water bottle in your
car uh the keys are my nice then he's
gonna catch them i think we should tell
him tonight yeah okay i just wanted to
make sure we did it the right way
which is definitely going to happen
[Music]
i think this is yours
i found something in your room you need
to explain
oh it's johnny lawrence's tie
if this is you trying to seem cool at
school or rebel against me or something
no no no it's it's not mine it's uh
there's this kid in school who's uh
who's in cobra kai you know he's been
giving me a hard time
oh you [ __ ] uh you know just messing
around uh yeah name calling stole my
girlfriend i promise i'm not gonna let
cobra guy hurt you
it's not that bad honestly no you're not
a little kid anymore
it's time
going up get changed oh he is joining me
[Laughter]
that's how you get into a doji you got
to lie and i can't take any more of
their crap
i'm ready to use my training and what do
you think you're gonna do kick their
asses
shave their heads your opponent's
weakness must be exploited and make no
mistake
we all have one sensei crease doesn't of
course he does
today no no the hell you say
you hit the mat you lose
you got it
all right prepare for combat some sick
gear you gave them care to make this
interesting what do you have in mind
they're gonna fight each other
well we need to choose a fighter
six-pack of brews to the winner
i like it they're the best sensei win
and chris just got his hair did too
so we wanted to talk to you
so
your mom and i are hooking up
i get it you guys are dating you're
dating yes
we're waiting for the right time and
place we wanted to take you to a nice
restaurant break the news to you
somewhere nice chilis or marine
calendars
i would have chosen someone with uh
better food in their refrigerator but
other than that sounds like a good guy
as long as you're happy i'm happy that's
not the reaction i was expecting i get
my water bottle now yes
okay
i'm starting up for
comrades
it might take some time for miguel to
get used to the situation
let's just
make sure we give him the room he needs
to adjust
[Music]
wow what a great first lesson
by giving me these you've dramatically
increased my odds of being stabbed to
death i thought you'd like it
well i mean you never said i get these
weapons you don't
not yet
[Music]
it might not be as exciting at level one
when you're learning all the controls
but the more you play
the more skills you're getting before
you know it level 12. you're hooked
mm-hmm i'll give you some of the cheat
codes along the way come on
oh my god as you can see i forgot to put
the covers on when i left last night oh
it's like a jackson pollock painting ah
i'm gonna show you exactly how to do it
and then you're gonna clean the cars
while i help mom down at the dealership
it's gonna be fun no question
nickels
oh here we go someone with no karate
experience what's her weakness her left
she telegraphs her kicks then you know
what to do
break her legs
[Music]
nice
[Music]
good one sensei crease
who's next the debate girl this is devin
lee
our new female champion hi
my pronouns are she her
the only pronouns we accept in this dojo
are sensei and students those are nouns
oh i'm sorry
i think what i meant to say
is quiet
[Laughter]
cobra kai doesn't follow the same rules
so we have to be ready for any dirty
trick they throw at us like when chong
lean through dirt into van damme's eyes
and bloodsport nice
like someone did their prep work and i
saw the sequels too not to mention delta
force billy jack the octagon and lady
dragon damn cynthia rothrock is a beast
hell yeah she is
it cynthia rothrock
all right everyone get ready cause today
i'm gonna put you through the ringer
except for you dias you're up here with
me what
tournament's right around the corner i
can't afford you getting hurt
besides this is gonna get a little
dangerous all right you'll be co-sensing
with me today sounds good
i i can do this sensei
i know you can but you're way above this
beginner stuff all right don't worry you
can help me out with the next lesson
no son
[Music]
pocket sand
ouch ouch
[Music]
i think miguel's happy he's not involved
in this lesson
yeah wearing cups right
it's a hurt with worthy cup double or
nothing
okay mr king can terry afford that many
beers i was gonna choose kenny
payne i wasn't gonna say that earlier as
a joke it's robbie's weakness
[Music]
[Music]
used his compassion against him don't
let your opponent think whatever they
want make them think what you want them
to think if they think you're weak
that's when you can surprise them with
your strengths
good job
good thing everyone thinks i'm weak
[Laughter]
always bringing that surprise
mom wants us to have a family dinner
tonight so
don't be home too late
ugh uh-oh it must be nice being
teacher's favorite uh is he gonna tuck
you in
you get your own place miguel
it's very easy to afford living in l.a
he actually did it hmm
already hired someone
can i help you yeah uh almost done i'm
just finishing up with the white walls
i'm a task rabbit i have a request
[Laughter]
you know i guess i just didn't want to
do it me neither but my cat needs hernia
surgery so i got the side hustle okay
could you just please leave okay see it
screw your cat yeah and you're not
getting paid for this
you know
i thought you were mature enough to
appreciate all this but i
yes i was wrong just got back to your
video games
it's gonna be peace now i'm gonna design
the greatest karate video game
oh where have you been you have to tell
me when you're gonna be home late i'm
sorry i lost track of time you lost
track of time
i was just hanging out with sam all
right see he was just hanging out with
his girlfriend i get it
we want you to be safe
okay always wear protection
johnny uh you let the girl decide that
just stop it
you said that nothing was going to
change and now everything has changed
it's weird at class it's weird here i'm
over it
that's a technique
that i hope none of us
will ever need to
use when you were born i brought you
home from the hospital and mr miyagi
wanted to pick you up he kicked him in
the face
it's the first time i ever saw anyone
land a kick on him
maybe you might want to learn a little
bit more about what this all means
you know and and to be able to defend
yourself against this bully
tell him you know don't worry about this
cobra cat kid
yeah
i handle it
oh goodness
i thought there was going to be milk in
there um kenny oh yeah he's hilarious
you guys are going to get along great
oh
it's got to hurt
this guy's just right there i just want
to talk
maybe we could try starting over
well i got nothing to say to you
la pusso
way to go kenny doesn't matter
he's trapped
come on let's find him
he's gonna
my god he's batman
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god it's batman i love it and then
it's gonna be like your thing darkness
[Music]
damn getting some jackie chan on
waiting go kenny
[Music]
hey what's going on in here
and he's gonna get suspended oh no
my dad left when i was in kindergarten
i barely remember him go out and try to
find him i don't even know what i'd say
maybe you could ask why he left hear his
side of the story
besides if i'm being honest i'm still
too afraid to find out the truth
um i took all that [ __ ] i felt from
them and i
put it on robbie's life i don't want to
make that mistake again damn you're
introspective dude i don't know there's
also a lot of things that i want to stay
the same
like you being my sensei
you asked for it i was gonna yell quiet
and i'm gonna kick you in the balls
i'm gonna say you should have been happy
you missed that lesson one of the most
badass kicks in all of karate
it's the flying tornado
okay did your dad know you're here
i told him i should be learning both
styles that's what i'm gonna do
she's your own woman i've already spoken
to the parents of the other offending
students involved and we're going to be
suspending them
and your son what
none of this is anthony's fault no i'm
afraid we have proof
turns out this isn't the first time your
son's a liar
i still don't know how they got all that
milk in a lot
i've seen enough evidence to conclude
that anthony has been a real bully this
year
i got you
kenny
kenny rise of kitty i'm vengeance well
those bomb we bought all 33s they've
changed a bit since the war
to the victor go the spoils so we
they're gonna fight i've poisoned all
but one we should remember
what happens to soldiers who don't
follow their leader very subtle honey
look is this about quiet
damn you told the students that i have a
weakness i said everyone has a weakness
no you specifically talked about me
[Music]
what do you think my weakness is it's
like did you not see part three i'm the
one who got you out of that cage then
only to find you in another one that you
created for yourself
i always looked out for you terry
but you need to fall back in line
god damn follow my lead
god daniel there's a lot of land mines
out there
[Music]
it's all gonna blow up
your weakness is miyagi do the acting
wow
this is no longer fun for terry
john i send you
to the arrow
see i've learned sensei
look at that quiet
i knew that was coming but i still
wasn't prepared
all right andrew you get dibs uh are we
doing easter eggs or what i thought
about the episode whatever you want to
do first all right well i thought that
was a really interesting episode it was
definitely a slow burn i liked a lot of
the character moments especially between
uh chris and terry silver obviously we
had anthony was a very major player in
this episode as well but just again
seeing the dichotomy and the evolution
of terry silver and john crease's
relationship is what i gravitate to
obviously that was my favorite part of
part three
chris you know not really being in the
movie much but still their relationship
is a very big deal to me so just
watching him like shift terry's whole
like just you know reality towards this
whole thing like was a very interesting
take and those two actors are freaking
so good i love that scene and the rest
of the episode like i said it was a slow
burn but i liked a lot of the character
moments also too specifically with
johnny and miguel i thought that took an
intro it definitely wasn't what i was
expecting because at first i think you
guys maybe too were expecting just to
freak out on them but i thought they
actually took a really interesting
direction on you know having to be okay
with it but then seeing how when
johnny's like just treating him like his
son and not you know treating him the
same as everyone else and then the
animosity he gets towards with the other
students i thought that was a really
interesting way to go and then you know
miguel having a totally natural reaction
like hey like if you're going to date my
mom fine but at least treat me
like it like the old ways you like
you've always treated me like a student
so you know it was uh i definitely
garnered i mean i already love miguel
he's one of my favorite characters but i
gained an even newfound perspective and
respect for this character just the way
he handled things you know progressively
and naturally i thought it was really
interesting that's a great point man
great great job great job john
absolutely i think uh show low i believe
is how you say his name he's gotten he's
i've always enjoyed him i've always
loved that character but especially this
season his performances are just
so natural and so like attuned to
whoever he's acting against and like
yeah just the way in which
it's almost subtle but you know the way
in which he sort of moved by the end of
his talk with johnny like i was
in the beginning of the episode i was
like is this you know plotline moving a
little quickly but especially for that
you know payoff i thought it was really
satisfying and yeah then to to flip over
to finally
danny and uh amanda having to deal with
the truth that you know
not all of their kids
are sam
and uh like you know the back and forth
between kenny and anthony and the way
that that bleeds over into you know the
fight between kenny and robbie and all
that stuff yeah like you said like the
the
the kind of trickle down of all these
different motivations of how everyone
sees their students how everyone's
trying to lead their students where
their students are at with their
motivation for using the training like
they've developed a really nice little
you know series of overlapping
situations that all feel very like
appropriately heightened but also
organic so yeah that's another strong
episode
you got easter eggs andrew there were a
couple i know so obviously we get
another bloodsport reference when we see
uh hear about bolo young's chong li when
he throws the powder into frank duke's
jungle fandam's face uh we get that uh
we did see a couple of the newspaper
postings and we see that picture of
miyagi and daniel holding each other's
hand that was from karate kid part three
one of the other newspaper clippings was
from the first film after uh he beat uh
um cobra kai yeah
after he beat cobrica what's the name oh
yeah cobra kai um but yeah there was
that uh we did see a couple of guys in
englefang punching uh some wood i
believe in karate kid part three daniel
also uh when he tore apart that whole uh
there was like a board when he after he
bloodied his knuckle he just broke
though and said i did it like so i guess
that was a reference to that and
uh we also did see a book that terry
silver was reading as the leviathan i
believe there was a film that came out
with peter weller might have been 1987 i
think um
yeah yeah but uh that was a that's a
creature from the ocean then we also
probably totally wrong on this one but
those uh those beers that they were
having at the end said three three three
and i kept on thinking well wait which
karate kid was terry silver and oh he's
on the third one so i guess that's i
don't know
damn it's good three three three
three's the best one especially scream
three mm-hmm
every part three man lethal weapon three
saw three
transformers three
batman forever greg do you have thoughts
on the episode got none nothing to say
all right that's gonna do it guys thanks
for being here
subscribe to andrew gordon's channel
check out john
i'm here and uh bye
but i did want to say oh oh
what twist ending
that's right i got
so many thoughts you got a litany
give me a topic i'll talk about a watch
anthony anthony which one's he uh he's
mapuso
yeah sorry
talk about daredevil batman and jackie
chan in the in the same scene yeah i
think uh i think all that stuff with
anthony is a very realistic way of
depicting this because it could have
gone down a path that was just super
cliche
versus you know like what i thought it
was gonna happen
like that mine was the more cliche route
that he would join miyagido to get
revenge at kenny in some way
this girl coming between them in a
divide it's cool how they're like
fleshing it out in a way that's very
karate kid familiar trope as we had with
um you know danny and johnny
and
elizabeth shoe ally
with an eye yeah with ally
that love triangle
robbie sam miguel and now here
with kenny anthony
the girl the female character
yeah
yeah the way that like how the hell the
conflict tends to center around female
very 80s very karate kid um and how that
brings up the most provocation when it
comes to these characters and with
anthony
i i really believe the way the
development would go with this character
after seeing him in three seasons as
this guy who was just i would forget
about him i'm not gonna lie they could
cut it out of the last one the reaction
on the bus when you first see kenny i
didn't recognize it i didn't recognize
him and it said larusso i was like is
this a flashback to daniel
that's what i think i cut it out uh
because yeah i completely forgot about
anthony larusso um in this show i think
they heard that meme yeah he looks
different from season one oh yeah the
kid's growing up and then you're like i
can actually make him a character now
and uh so it's it is an interesting way
to flush him out where he does no they
they have a good grade that they have
with him he's not full bully he just
gets provoked but i also believe in that
whole thing with him feeling like left
out man to me though kenny was the
standout [ __ ] kenny
batman scene
tears so cool kenny batman daredevil
jackie chan that was great what jackie
chan where he's jumping through the the
light the the book shelf that's a jackie
chan move come on that's a move but like
jackie chan never does like
movement shadows okay fine yeah okay
fine man
yeah okay so yeah maybe he's a little
more head-on just like tony
but
batman and daredevil that means i think
we can agree on that okay
we'll agree let's not fight and split
our dojos yes so with the batman and
daredevil and the jackie chan reference
possibly ip man
that scene was so cool just to watch
kenny take revenge and i i i wonder if
he manipulated the camera worked
like he seemed like he intentionally led
them to the library because you knew
like i'm gonna shut down the lights i
can control the environment this is my
environment this is my land now my
gotham city and as the world's greatest
detective and then taking him to the
cameras like he knew he got him uh was
was really great i i really like that
and yeah i think like the terry and and
creasing because that's something we've
talked about is who's really in control
here and i you go to see the fear it is
it's like crease is using his trauma to
like terry's trauma
to because terry clearly has so much of
that to the point where it can hinder
him that's like when we first met up
with him he was weak
now i wouldn't say weak but he wasn't
like he he was prone to being affected
by the trauma and whereas crease is like
i own my trauma yeah
i own that [ __ ] it's made me who i am
i'm a man i do my bane
power pose hey bane stole that from him
just saying that's true yeah it's true
man tom hardy has no originality in his
performances
so to to have that scene where like that
got that gets me tenses my butt my brain
is going damn crease is scary the other
part of me is you know if terry just
like focus up here i think he could kick
creases i feel like between the two
fighters i feel like terry's probably
from an actor's standpoint is a better
fighter than creases martin cove
um but in terms of character he knows
how to use that intimidation which was a
pretty rad sandwich at the time
i just uh also thought about this too
when he said take him down it kind of
felt a little bit like when he was uh
speaking um ah blanking on his name
right now but he uh and you guys kill me
in the comment section but he said to
him get him out of commission in the
first film when he was telling him uh
oh yeah
uh and then uh yeah but yeah i agree
with you yeah yeah i mean this is a lot
of this is about overcoming trauma
that's a big part of what i think make
cobra kai so special uh when in terms of
like keeping what's great about those
movies and the love for them
while also deconstructing or not even
really deconstructing but exploring i
would say
and
you know with like johnny like this guy
doesn't need therapy apparently he could
just do all his work on his own it's
incredible
of all that stuff about what made him
the way he is and why his relationship
with robbie fell apart and just learning
like i just got to be honest with miguel
and then go from there you know i think
that's
that's some awesome stuff yeah good
episode guys bobby that was his name
thank god you recovered yes god i think
and
i'm probably wrong too but i think
leviathan was 1989 i think robocop was
87 for peter weller leviathan is a
mythical creature i understand this
[Music]
fun facts
um all right guys well what'd you think
about this episode leave your thoughts
down below you can subscribe click that
bell
hit that like button get accepted into
the reject nation today by turning on
the notification bells
last but not least let's do a
david gandy i'm surprised we didn't
shout you out already for this
because david gandy i believe is
i'm trying to get us an actual age
instead of my typical joke of going so
old 28. he's 28 years old
but he looks 50.
and uh he actually took up some martial
arts not long ago i don't know how
that's going with you man i remember
there's a big time where you were really
into that you were disciplined you were
watching how really changed your life a
lot of times we might take people's
names here on patreon and go if there's
anyone at our patreon page
and then john just lists things about
the show or the movie but i'm here to
tell you that that's not just the case
there's really if there's anyone on our
patreon page who really represents
what it's like to
get involved in a dojo a little bit late
in your life and then watch as your life
just changes transform it's you man you
are literally the only one
at our patreon page you should be a part
of this show so david thank you so much
for being here for so many years sensei
gandy this mother effer has never
decreased his pledge sure that makes him
top tier that means you're a black belt
in our eyes you're a lethal weapon what
year did that come out 1987 the second
one was 89 the third one was 92 and the
third fourth one was 98 and when's the
new one coming out your guess is as good
as mine when mel gibson approves of the
script
2029 all right
let's go
[Music]